so this is supposed to be the slow time
of year but that's not true if you live
in Japan no no it's not what happened
today got a trailer it looks really
awesome it's supposed to come out this
year both in North America and Japan
more places in 3 and PlayStation 4 and
he's sort of he's did early last year
and then announced it but this is the
first actual book that we've got at the
game it's a big deal
people love persona 4 I love persona 4
oh yeah and all of its various spin-offs
ya know and this trailer was like a
really exciting reveal of the game cuz
we really haven't seen anything of that
yet most of what we saw was sort of you
know the main character moving around
the city which is you know the game is
set in Tokyo news shabooya shabooya yeah
and we didn't get to see any combat that
I recall right
we did we did all combat later on in the
trailer it showed the UI kind of looks
like previous persona games okay um it's
very similar but towards the end they do
show the three characters sort of
flipping around like some of their
personas you can use guns that's a big
thing I noticed in this game is there
are guns like there's they show the UI
but in the in the UI they have you
picked the weapon and it's a gun and we
haven't really seen people use guns very
much in combat in persona games so
that's new yeah um I like that the the
normal walking around the world looks
like Catherine like the game looks like
Catherine the graphics are way better
than persona 4 and it looks like
conversations won't be like we didn't
see any menus where you know an avatar
popped up and there was text on the
screen we saw them sitting around a
table over a map talking like I wonder
if that's what cutscenes will be in
persona 5 will be actual cutscenes
instead of having an avatar talk which
would be awesome
yeah because they've had a few anime
movies based in the persona series based
on three and four lately it's time
wonder if they're kind of pulling from
that in regards to those games like did
you notice any connections to some of
the characters or the world even the
timing okay so there are two things
number one they show Igor with looks
like two new assistants right in what
and then they show the velvet room but
the velvet room looks kind of like a
jail now they show it twice which is
interesting but I noticed in the on the
upper left corner they have the date and
the date is April 11th 411 and that time
in April is where persona 3 and persona
4 were those the events of those games
kickoff so I'm wondering like do these
games occur are they occurring all at
the same time or is it like apparently
know whatever they do with persona but I
just think it's interesting that like
that date is like there it's like so
significant yeah this is a series of
like a really passionate fan base so
Atlas is basically just stoking that
fire and everyone something that I
noticed is in the the part of the
trailer where they show the kitty cat
running around and they have the words
across the screen they're all words that
relate to the seven deadly sins like you
have lust and gluttony and like and
anger and greed and stuff like that and
I'm wondering how that is going to play
into the game my guess is they show
those characters around a map and then
they show those four kids running around
or the three kids running around in like
full full-on suits and like the main
protagonist has up like tuxedo mask mask
on and they're sort of hidden and I'm
wondering if they are some sort of like
vigilante group like running around the
city and if that ties in to that or if
they're maybe like bad kids
if this persona stars like really bad
kids so I'm really interested to see
where that goes they also I noticed the
the dungeons they showed the main
character jumping on chandeliers and
sort of nuvaring around and it looks
like they've added some platforming and
then stealth elements to dungeons when
he was still going through the hallway
he's jumping over chandeliers and stuff
yeah yeah that's me as well like I'm not
sure how I feel about that
I love I'm kinda excited for it and then
when he was still thing up the hallway
like enemies don't appear is like a
shapeless whatever like you can see
what's ahead of you I think that that
game will sort of it's moving away from
you know the avatars talking and like
this sort of other like more classic
ways of doing dungeons and stuff and I
think this is gonna be a big deal like I
can tell the atlases put a lot of time
and thought into making this game it's
it looks awesome